[Music]
hi everyone I'm Cyrus I am the product
lead for Chromebooks in the commercial
segment which means education business
government that whole deal everything
other than you walking in the Best Buy
basically so here to talk a little bit
about Chrome Enterprise give you a sneak
peek and the stuff that's coming and
then I will try to save time at the end
for questions because I think that's
actually the most fun part things you
want to know about how it works
interesting behind the scenes stuff
there's mics up here or you can shout it
out as soon as we get to to Q&A I'll try
to leave 10 to 15 minutes at least for
Q&A so just you know jot down Google
keep whatever here questions oh this is
where I'm supposed to introduce myself
oops that's a pretty interesting black
and white they did um so I've been on
the binnacle 13 years this year he's a
long time that's a very long time at
Google standards um and I've been on
Chrome OS specifically next year will be
10 years so I was on the initial team
which is pretty exciting so I've seen it
seen the whole ride I was actually when
I first joined they said what do you
want to work on so we have like you know
two product managers and I said I said I
you know my background is in enterprise
I said I think this product will do well
in a managed environment with IT because
they love the idea of a simple secure
endpoint so that's what I did I worked
on the very first prototype cr-48 does
anyone remember the cr-48
no yes pupae that's there go back to
three people remember that it's a long
time ago it's probably worth money on
eBay if you have one by the way because
we only made sixty thousand I was given
16 thousand to give out to schools and
businesses to go try out and say would
you like a device like this a lot of
your employees are living on the web
what do you think and and they said yes
can you please take my money I don't
think this much better than what I'm
doing so we thought we were onto
something and so it's been quite a
journey in the decade that's followed
and the stuff that we've added and stuff
that we've done so I'll talk a little
bit about about that I like to start
with a little bit of context people
wonder why why are you making computers
who guys do all kinds of strange things
although now they ask that lessons we
have you know driverless cars and all
kinds of strange things going on the
background just so you know this company
was born on the web everything we do is
web right and we want to make sure that
we give people the best web experience
so we would optimize the web we really
push the boundaries for those of you
remember the web used to be of course
static web pages and then we slowly kind
of to push the boundaries and to do
actual applications right Gmail was kind
of one of its kind embedded chat Google
Maps right over the initial age actually
can like zoom and all these kind of
things we're very revolutionary at the
time we were pushing the envelope
bandwidth was still painful like very
painful for those of you that remember
dial tones sent what you had to go
through and so then we spun up efforts
to improve bandwidth and that's come a
tremendous way right two or three
different projects we've had at least in
bandwidth and then it became like 8 or 9
projects so we had bandwidth we had
great web apps and then you had this
browser that was just painful you had
toolbars you guys remember toolbars
people had three or four different
toolbars the Google toolbar it's very
popular and people had three big and
then big buttons for back
and forward and like that entire part of
your screen took up 50% of your screen
and then there's this small portion
below that you would actually scroll to
actually get to the content and the part
around the actual content is called the
chrome of the browser so of course you
know kind of tongue-in-cheek we decided
to call it Chrome because we actually
wanted to get away Google's in a very
unique position where we're not actually
interested in staying in our products
for long periods of time if you think of
search we win when you're out of there
fast you've got your answer and you move
on right same with Chrome our goal is to
get out of the way make the content
front and center and so that's actually
why we went out into chrome we tried to
work with the other browser providers we
worked hard it was very very hard and
when we came out with this in 2009 or
eight it was uh a lot of people said do
we need another browser there's already
so many browsers and of course now
chrome I think most of you know is doing
pretty well largest browser in the world
two billion people use the chrome
browser on a weekly basis which is just
staggering when you think about that
so we we kind of addressed web browsing
and then there was a the last problem
the third big problem as you would turn
on your computer and you would go to get
coffee and you would go take a nap and
then you would come back and it would
still be booting and then when you
finally got in you know startup would
take forever you would log in and and
pop-ups would come in and know you and
you were just waiting to click the
browser button to get on with your life
and a lot of people can't even remember
this it has been a while this was the
state of computing it would get slower
over time if any of you have a five six
year old desktop computer in your
basement you know exactly what I'm
talking about you probably never want to
turn on that thing again right it's loud
you don't even know what's going on and
I think this was the computing world
back then the cheapest computer at the
time was four hundred and fifty dollars
when we started our journey and we came
out with this completely radical hundred
and ninety nine dollar computing
fastest way to get on the web in the
world five seconds to boot so it's very
revolutionary the time and a lot of
analysts credit the Chromebooks and the
journey we've been on for kind of
completely changing how computing works
and this is a little bit from our
journey it's a lot we've done in ten
years when you look at chrome and Chrome
OS when when Chromebooks came out a lot
of people will even remember this this
is now way dating chrome version nine I
think eight or nine you didn't even have
multiple windows it was just literally a
single browser full screen that was it
you couldn't minimize and I this strange
as this sounds they drove people crazy
that there was no wallpaper I said I
want to see my wall band we said well
there's nothing to see there's no
applications to pin there's nothing it's
just the web and they said well I still
want to minimize it so I can see the
wallpaper there was this very straight
stick so we actually did that we gave
them the ability to slide it away and
look at a picture um but that was the
very first iteration of Chromebooks we
then added all kinds of features for
schools we added kiosk mode and we added
this cool feature called managed guest
sessions we used to be called public
sessions which is this completely
ephemeral way of running a Chromebook
and we then added the entire Play Store
which is crazy the two million or
whatever applications so you have the
entire mobile application ecosystem on a
full desktop browser which is also never
been done
we recently she just launched in 73 the
enterprise controls for full Linux
application support so a lot has
happened in a short period of time so
let's go in and look at some of the
myths that are out there about Chrome OS
I think these are fun first
you're only an edu play what the heck
well first of all I can tell you about
edu phenomenal growth in education as
you probably know we are number one in
many countries every
quarter to 2/4 we become number one in
another country almost 70% share in the
United States in education so phenomenal
growth but the good news is it's been
growing in all the other segments
extremely well this is the non edu this
is like the business growth of Chrome OS
and you can see this is a good trend
we're on the right side of the trend
right as companies move to the cloud
this is exactly what they want they want
a secure endpoint that is fast that is
shareable etc so the rest of the PC
market unfortunately fortunately is
fairly flat in many areas it's negative
one percent negative six percent overall
in the commercial segment it's it's
right around flat one to two percent so
this is very good for us to see and the
good news is is accelerating not just
saying that way a lot of companies using
it people ask who's actually is this a
real thing and they're using it for a
variety of reasons they're not just
using it for your frontline workers as
people using it for information records
people using it all day long using it
for content management they're using it
for ERP they're using it for
point-of-sale all kinds of use cases out
there and this is obviously a very small
sample of some of the customers that are
out there
do you have enterprise class Chromebooks
yes oh yeah of course it won't work oh
it does kind of work this device is an
example I I was going to I don't know if
I can mention the name but I was going
to a large hotel chain and I went to
their call center and there's thousands
and thousands of people in this call
center and you know taking reservations
handling support and I said oh this is
awesome what application are they using
what are they doing and they said and
this was before Chromebooks even lines
they said I said what are they using and
they said well they're just using the
web they just use Chrome all day and I
said oh that's fantastic these chrome
all day
are they useing he said well we've given
them Mac minis I said Mac admit that's a
pretty fancy thing and you're only in
the browser of the eye and he said so
pain people take them they steal them
you know the shift a there's and so as I
said my gosh that's you know do you want
something better like as you just want
the web and they said yes absolutely
this but we need a headless device
because we have big monitors we want to
have our standard keyboards so we don't
want a laptop form factor so I actually
went back I went back to our team and I
said can you make me something small no
battery no keyboard no monitor and we
actually did that we actually came out
with the chrome box and actually the
reason I gave that story is because we
actually made these devices for
enterprises right this is actually
encourage a lot of them now almost all
the OEMs make these chrome box as well
but we've got chrome boxes we've got
Chromebooks
we've got convertibles and 360s we've
got detachable --zz we have tablets we
have stylists we have all the way to i7
units we have core i5 you you can get 16
gig units you can get Chromebooks at her
up to $1500 Chromebooks every major Oh
am I making books so you can absolutely
get enterprise class Hardware any form
factor you want touch 4k all of those
cool things so that's another good thing
to know oh good here we go did I do it
okay good
they don't really work offline gosh it's
the number of people that have told me
this there's a lot of people that
actually and I'm not kidding when I say
this probably 10 times I've been asked
this is this amazing how does it work so
there's no disk at all the disk is in
the cloud no no these are still
computers they have a disk they have
everything offline you need a disk for
caching and all of those types of things
um so it absolutely works offline it can
work the web has offline of course
assuming your web provider has made
offline work and then of course the
entire Android ecosystem is available
those applications all of those 2
million were actually built off
first day all of them assumed offline in
a lot of cases almost all applications
including web applications will
obviously work better in some cases work
only on the web
meaning when you're online that's to be
expected but getting developers to start
building offline first is actually very
good it's a good thing for them to do
anyway because the applications tend to
be much quicker they work better in
flaky connections they handle things
like syncing etc so I usually encourage
developers if possible build in that
mode right in that way of thinking
there's a tons and tons of offline
applications available on Chromebooks
which is just good to know does it only
do the browser well ok I think probably
covered that a few times of course it
has the whole mobile application
ecosystem which again is I think a super
cool unique thing when you think about
where people are building apps today no
one is dusting off their dotnet and
c-sharp books and building for Windows
they're building for the web or they're
building for mobile that's it and so the
good news is when you think about that
it's actually really really great to
have the entire mobile application
ecosystem available as well as the full
desktop browser which is kind of very
very unique in addition I mentioned
running Linux apps and it probably is
worth saying you can also run legacy
Windows applications on a Chromebook
which is great there's lots and lots of
ways to do it there are providers that
stream Windows apps down you can use
on-premise virtualization there's even
on device virtualization options
available now that we have Linux so that
you can run your Windows applications
kind of a little bit inception but you
know there's there lots of personal jobs
so if you really want to but the main
thing we want to do is for all of these
make sure that it is ultra ultra secure
none of these should open up new
security holes
everything is containerized everything
is sandbox nothing it's access to the OS
in general anyway the OS has read-only
and blocked from anyone updating it on a
lot of other operating systems when you
inst one of the reasons viruses happen
and computers get slow is
because applications once they're
installed becomes super users right they
can basically do anything they can
modify the u.s. they can write to
different parts of the register they can
just kind of litter themselves all over
for those of you that remember the and
it's very hard to change this in an OS
although OSS are absolutely all getting
better it's very very hard even
uninstall was a big problem in the olden
days you had to go out and find all of
the bits that might have been littered
out threw up your operating system this
was just built an extremely different
way hmm
oh there we go well my clicker sometimes
doesn't work they may need to stand here
what about regular updates how does that
all work so our update mechanism is
different and I think this is one of the
extremely unique things about
Chromebooks every Monday morning whether
you're at school or at a business and
all of your employees lift the lids and
start working they're all running
exactly the same version of the OS which
is in itself remarkable all updates are
delivered entirely from the cloud
there's nothing to do on Prem etcetera
but there's a few differences with how
we do updates first of all all updates
are completely seamless to the user
they're done in the background and the
reason we can do them in the background
is every Chromebook has two versions of
the operating system at all times
there's an A and a B copy as you're
running on a B gets updated and of
course they do we don't update the whole
thing it's just Delta updates right
every six weeks or whatever we're just
the bits that need to change or changed
as soon as we reboot as soon as the user
reboots and by the way because it's so
fast this is another interesting tidbit
that a lot of people don't even know
most people at Google don't know this
because booting it's so fast because
it's like five six seconds when you log
out and you get back to the login screen
if an update is ready we will actually
do a full reboot and take you back to
the login screen and most people don't
know that logout took a few extra
seconds and they're back at the login
screen but we've actually not only done
a full reboot but we've swapped and we
are now running
on OSB is the primary OS at the same
time that we do that two of the seconds
of the boot are actually taken up by
something we call verified boot which is
actually an entire process to verify the
operating system we verify every bit of
the operating system to make sure it is
exactly what we expect so in the event
that we have missed something and
something squeaked through and was able
to compromise the OS we won't even let
you boot with that OS we will revert
back to a and boot so this is actually
all the stuff that goes on when you boot
a Chromebook and it's all happens
completely in the background which is
pretty nice I think that's good on this
I kind of started alluding to this right
how can they be so secure if there's no
antivirus I don't get it and I cannot
tell you how many companies is that I
don't get it I really wanted antivirus
and I said well I don't know what to
tell you there's no such thing you
cannot have a virus I shouldn't say that
you don't need an anti-virus as of now
because there is no such concept as
something compromising the OS in a
persistent way that wouldn't be detected
when you boot so one how do we do this
and how is this even been possible after
10 years of employees and hackers and
students by the way students are some of
the best hackers in the world because
they want nothing more than to use their
computer to go surf inappropriate things
and so it's really fantastic that we
have penetrated all of that first is the
OS itself it's kind of kept completely
locked down
nothing gets access to the OS again I
can tell you some all kinds of
interesting stories since I've been on
the team for so long but there's a
there's a small shell that you can
actually run called the cross shell for
those of you that know about this we can
actually run some basic commands they
didn't take an entire operating system
and then build Chrome OS on top of that
they actually did the opposite they said
we need the Chrome browser what are the
minimum pieces we need underneath it to
make it work period that's what we're
going to put in
the command paying for those of you that
know what that command is the most basic
simple command in the world there was an
email thread about whether we should
allow ping they look with that level of
detail because every single thing you
add is a potentially another vector
another threat so they're very very very
careful about what they add nothing can
get into the operating system if any
channel is open to get access to the
operating system it's only done under
using private Google api's that we have
the second thing we do is we sandbox
everything we sandbox the entire browser
process within the browser process we
sandbox each tab the entire Android
container is sandbox every app within
the Android container then in a separate
sandbox so things you know
defense-in-depth is of course used in
security and physical security and in
software security this is exactly what
you want things would have to hop out of
many many containers and sand boxes to
get access then I mentioned we also have
verified boot in case we've missed
something and of course we have humans
that do all kinds of reviewing of
extensions and apps we also have which
is pretty cool we have a lot of AI and
ml that actually reviews all of the
application and application updates that
come in the Play Store in the webstore
things are automatically taken down
before a human even sees it which is
also pretty cool I'm just very hard to
do given the scale is this an enterprise
class device can I run this in my
company well the good news is yes
there's a lot of stuff in there there is
200 plus different policies that you can
set the good news is almost no one sets
anything close to that this they need
like 15 or 16 different controls at most
but the options are there if you need a
lot of advanced stuff there's full fleet
management here but the nice thing I
will say about this is the stuff that's
in here is entirely cloud-based so the
entire management of your fleet is
entirely cloud-based right a lot of
people don't know this but our
management system it's the largest
cloud-based EMM in the world
MVM for those of you that know what that
is no cloudy mm in the world manages as
many devices as this one does tens of
millions of active devices running
another 10 million devices just in
education gets enrolled into the console
in just a period of a few months in July
in August and Google doesn't feel it at
all right it's one of the benefits of
having the scale the IT administrator
can be on their phone on their car ride
home
hopefully not while driving and can
actually go in and make changes look at
their fleet disable the device lock one
down if it's stolen those types of
things you can do all of that entirely
from here which is nice
provisioning a Chromebook and rolling a
Chromebook for those of you that done it
is thinking about seven seconds I mean
you think about a different OS I won't
say who how long that takes to provision
that and enroll that and image that and
get that with all the applications that
you need it's not seven seconds so
that's pretty exciting and of course all
the applications extensions everything
you do is done from here as well which
is kind of nice and I think this may be
the last myth I don't know but let's see
can you integrate with your legacy IT
world because I have a legacy and how do
I handle that and every company does
though which is a good news unless
you're a small business very small SMB
or you grew up in a Cerberus
company which the new ones do
fortunately most new companies don't
bring out big servers and stick them
onto their desks so yes there's lots of
options here first of all you can
actually if you really love Active
Directory and SCCM and group policy you
can manage your Chromebooks using that
it's more painful name value pairs and
JSON blobs but if you really love that
that can be how you manage your
Chromebooks you can you can of course
access MS Office if you need for your
employees there's actually lots of
different ways to do that of course
there's native web ways to do that
there's Android versions to do that
there's the full office functionality we
really need
that team that needs the Excel macros
and their VB stuff from 1997 so all of
that is there and SSL Certificates 802
and a ether at all all of the stuff that
you think you might need are we done
no there's an enormous list of stuff
that companies need but the good news is
whenever we talk to us almost every CIO
I've ever talked to I don't need to
convince them that this is a better
model for them anyone that's ever tried
it and test it is like I love it I want
to expand this but they say this is the
stuff I need right so that's exactly the
right place to be right we are in
exactly the right situation because
we're on the right side of the trend we
already have natural pull from CIOs so
it's just a matter of making sure this
has all the enterprise capabilities it's
an entire dedicated team that just works
on making sure you've got all of the
enterprise functionality you need of
course you could run it today you'd have
to do some workarounds etcetera but we
want you to be able to run it with
everything that you possibly need okay
okay what's coming up now the sneak
peeks now no photos is this what true no
photos no no photos for this part there
will be some very exciting stuff here
so this part here is a little bit a
sneak into what's coming and how we
think about the vision of Chromebooks in
the future when we think about
everything that we're building we really
think about two sections right the first
is of course we're talking about for the
end-user that's where our life begins
that's our world secure and productive
those are the two things that we want to
make sure that they are they're secure
and they're productive okay and we'll
talk about those in a second and the
second piece of course is the IT
department many times unfortunately more
important than the end-user because
they're also the ones buying and
deciding and deploying and doing all of
that making sure that they have very
powerful easy-to-use endplate manage
is very important and we'll talk about
both of these really quick and I'll give
you some glimpses and the stuff that is
coming which i think is pretty cool
let's talk briefly about the end-user
the first thing is very assistive we
want to it's and when I say a system by
the way I don't mean the Google
assistant which is amazingly cool you
can ask it a question you can do
hands-free assistant now on Chromebooks
and you can just say the magic words
which I won't say or everyone here with
an Android phone listen to my voice but
um but being able to ask good questions
and all that is great but what we mean
here is when you think about an
operating system today every operating
system you ever used whether you're
using Windows or using you know fruit or
whatever you're using when you use it
it's a very reactive system right it's
just waiting it's sitting there and it
says tell me wait for me to click
something and it's not helpful right it
should actually know you're about to
enter the meeting that you entered at
the same time yesterday with the same
three people and should just nudge you
and say hey by the way this is the
presentation you guys are working on the
last time do you want to open it right
it should do it only if it has an
extremely high confidence level that
that's what it is right that's how all
AI and ml is all just based on
probability but that's actually what it
should do these are simple things to do
actually if you are a company you know
with AI in ml instinctively but these
are the types of things that you're
going to start seeing you're going to
see an operating system that is actually
going to help you now interestingly by
the way there's a lot of AI and ml
actually within a Chromebook today that
a lot of people don't know there's
amazingly cool stuff and they're not
just machine learning around your
preferences are on brightness and time
of day and how light how much you like
it and adjusting it your your personal
habits when you're running different
apps for what we should discard how to
optimize your battery life your
performance when we should crank it up
all of those types of things are
actually there on is actually on device
ml that is running those things to make
it smart in the background but we want
smart even for the end user direct
for their applications the next one is
productive it's also extremely important
for those of you that live like me with
29 tabs open or probably 70 and they all
just become these tiny little icons does
anyone have to use a lot of tabs like I
do yes
it drives me insane first of all I can't
even see what it is and that also drives
me insane so fixing that that is all
coming do not worry there's absolutely
going to be better tab management and
tab groupings and all kinds of things
but even taking it a step further to be
able to have of course multiple desktops
this has been around operating system
for a long time but doing even cooler
things like if you are in a different
mode or in a different workspace being
able to take all of that work and name
it as a workspace keep it synced on any
device that you use get into focus mode
so right now I'm only in this workspace
and I don't want to be disturbed or
accidentally go to any other things all
of those types of things we have seen
that they work and so you should see a
lot of this cool stuff coming out
flexibility of course is important I've
already covered this slide but just want
to bring it up again that it's very
important that people work the way they
like if you are the type of person that
really prefers touch or you really
prefer a tablet you really prefer
detachable and you want to take out the
keyboard every once in a while you
should be able to have that option and
then IT what's coming in this space so
I'm two things they care about
I want to do everything I can possibly
do and I want it to be easy to use when
you think about what IT departments care
about they usually want two things right
they want visibility and they want
control but visibility means I just
wanna be able to see and know everything
that's going on what are people
installing what are they doing are they
driving me crazy what security things
are they doing now and they want to make
it really really really easy to control
those things so first thing is simple I
mentioned this before we have obviously
a ton of policies but we also do
something very simple called smart
defaults where we actually go through
every single policy and make sure that
it's already set to what we think will
be the best
experience and the most secure for you
we always err on the side of the more
secure option and then let you turn
things on as you want this means you
don't need to go mess with 50 things to
get it running you can actually do none
of them and then you can slowly decide
which things you want to turn on to
control turn off etc so this one I
talked about scalable I mentioned this
tens of millions of devices handled
entirely from the cloud you never need
to worry about adding new servers or
anything to manage your devices which i
think is great
there are several deployments of
Chromebooks with more than a hundred
thousand devices at any organization
both schools and businesses and what's
actually even more interesting than that
is most of them didn't hire a single
additional IT person which is staggering
when you think about a hundred and
eighty thousand in one situation and
they didn't hire anyone additional oh
good thank you so much you can come see
me I'll probably be here for one minute
[Music]